[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your place the
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]
are you Tom hi here we are we're back
hey you found that jumper you lost that
last week I did I lost it and it's my
favorite jumper and uh I thought I'd
left it here like months ago but then I
found it in my my cupboard my wardrobe
you look you look cuddly in that ugly
and cuddly I went right to the back of
the Wardrobe my dog was there sleeping
and I went further back ended up Narnia
supposedly dogs and cats love their
humans wardrobes because the olfactory
situation in there the stench or smell
of their owner is pungent in the
wardrobe and they love it well that's
the first time I've ever seen Bobby in
there right but uh it was nice to see
him and there he was enjoying himself we
took him yesterday to a restaurant he
was very well behaved wasn't it he's
very well behaved in restaurants you can
take him anywhere Bob how's your week
been anything stand out anything
specific somebody was very uh very
aggressive and not very nice on League
of Legends to me this way
it was a Lulu oh Lulu's usually nice
she's a little pixie I know but she says
I was one of the worst players she'd
ever seen
well that's terrible we don't need any
of that stuff other than that Tom things
have been good actually the weather's
been nice uh yeah it's been all right no
not nothing really to report what about
you
try to think not a huge amount has been
going on with me that my Garden's waking
up so lots of
um
spring kind of plants uh peeking the
heads up above the soil which is always
nice to see got a few more animals I've
got myself a baby praying mantis well
done we've got a Jerusalem cricket
lovely three whip scorpions three of the
best
yeah three whips nothing nothing like it
I went to an insect convention in Pomona
were they just signing things yeah
they're all just hanging out with each
other uh people selling stuff people
talking about insects and reptiles and
stuff what I like about those things is
similar to any of these other
conventions that we've been to
everyone's everyone loves those animals
so you're now in a group of people that
all feel good things about those
creatures so you're hearing stuff like
Oh What a Beautiful spider what what a
cool snake that's a great lizard instead
of ew what's that oh that's scary you
know yeah unless somebody's went to a
convention by accident and dressed as
like Doctor Who or something yeah and
they get terrified yeah and my car drove
me there because I have a self-driving
car now self-driving cars now that we'll
talk about that another week but that
that is a whole thing to get into that's
changing the world is it not yeah it is
it's crazy and also it will probably in
the next 20 or 30 years or so
start to really alleviate traffic around
the world because a self-driving car
will make decisions to stop you from
being in a traffic jam whereas we know
most traffic jams are
created by someone hitting the brake
aggressively and then someone else does
the same yeah or people changing lanes
all the time they don't need to they
don't need to Dom just to get four
seconds ahead of where they were a
self-driving car won't do that so
hopefully it is changing the world in a
great way and it's an electric car and
all that kind of stuff hey we have some
housekeeping come on Tom let's let's do
it
peeling The Onion
um please keep sending in your
suggestions as to where to put the swear
words in each uh Lord of the Rings film
because we're continuing to hear some
very fun ones there but we wouldn't I
love that thing that's great but we
would just like to reach out to whoever
last week centers the Momofuku chili
crunch which we used so good on billion
Dominique the world we ate half a jar we
loved it we do not have the name of said
person and we'd like to say thank you
for that so please I've been thinking of
thanking that person all week because it
was absolute to the point my sister was
listening to the podcast and she tried
to order some and it's been sold out
done oh probably because of the podcast
yeah because it was so delicious and
we'd love to have the person the chef
who makes the Momofuku chili crunch on
the podcast so if you're around Madame
or sir and you'd like to be on the
podcast we'd like to have you too also
you have a great story about a gift that
was said to us about a bracelet John
hold on come on tell us about that
okay so last week Billy and I opened up
these are they called emergency
bracelets well I can't remember this is
another thing because sadly me and Dom
opened this and not someone in the cast
office and we we obviously are very
thankful but we lost the letter and
someone made these wonderful bracelets
if you're on YouTube you could probably
see that if you're just listening then
it's a sort of bracelet made from one
piece of rope and it sort of you know
braided like you know a young horse's
mane great and then it's got a really
cool clasp on it and you can wear it as
a bracelet just thus yes and uh but I
was like why is it an emergency when are
you going to use it as an emergency
thing yeah and I was going to look it up
but it didn't and then my son went
surfing in the morning I picked him up
with like some you know trousers and
stuff that you can wear at school and he
said did you bring my bill I didn't
bring his bill and his trousers are
quite big that's the way baggy pants the
young people well
they're staying up without a belt and
he's like I can't wear these and I went
hold on
I've got an emergency bracelet and key
ring
that in the back of the car here I got
the key ring I unraveled
because it was an emergency yeah I
unraveled the Rope of the key ring and
it was enough to make him a belt see so
we really want to say thank you to the
people who sent us the emergency
bracelets and keyrings but me and Tom
have sadly lost the letter so please if
you send us something send us an email
as well so that we can um we can look
that up but thank you very much you
saved you saved the day and you saved my
son's dignity he didn't stroll around
all day with his pants at his ankles yes
that's true and uh yeah we very much
appreciate you guys sending us stuff
that we can use on the podcast and if
you'd like to send this stuff
the address is oh let's see if Dom gets
this right I don't think we've ever done
this before no that can't be right no
that's not right I've got the wrong one
but if you do want to send us an email
you can do that at the Friendship onion
at cursemedia.com that's a cast with the
key the address for the Friendship onion
is one four eight zero Vine Street Los
Angeles California
90028 if you just put in a little bit of
information uh about whatever you're
sending to us we can uh shout you guys
out on the show love it or send us a
voicemail at speakpape.com forward slash
the Friendship onion now as we're
peeling the onion and looking back at uh
last week's episode and weeks before Dom
there is a little bit of embarrassment
for uh Johnny kaluz is that yeah that's
Johnny close is well known uh for his
incredible Lord of the Rings uh quizzes
and there the question things that you
know need to be answered hence Johnny
Clues
Tom you get one of the questions wrong
again really yeah last week's quiz with
the lovely sisters Audrey and Ali now
I can't remember who won
out of Audrey and Ally but I tell you
what it might have been Ali but it
should have been Audrey because uh one
of the questions was who is Mary first
cousins to and uh Johnny Cruz uh told us
it was uh Frodo and to be honest Tom we
are Mary and Pepin and we should have
known to be honest and especially with
John's history
and they're getting things right and but
it was actually Pippin as his first
cousin which I think was her guess it
was her guess so actually
Audrey one we've failed you ladies sorry
from Mississippi we'd like to send you
both a T-shirt and we will just get back
down John Mark that down two T-shirts
he's looking at he looks quite
embarrassing yeah but yeah he looks
sheepish yeah very sheepish you're both
winners
um well we've got one of you is more or
winner than the other yeah that's true
one of you actually has one and the
other one has come second
Dom did you know that 203 men will
experience some form of hair loss but a
time of 35. wow is that is that right
listen I I'm come from England come from
Manchester where hair for men is very
important and you know if I'm gonna
start losing some of it maybe I might go
in the direction of keeps because keeps
offers a simple stress-free way to keep
your hair oh yes convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't even have to
leave the house low cost treatments
start at ten dollars a month Dom and
keeps offers generic versions they also
have discrete packaging and proven
results keeps us more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key treatments can take four to six
months to see results so act fast act
now if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k e e p s.com
slash onion to receive your first month
of treatment for free wow that's k e e p
s.com slash onion to get your first
month free
k-e-e-p-s.com slash onion
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's Professional Therapy done
securely online there is a broad range
of expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available better help want you to start
living a happier life today visit
betterhelp.com onion that's better
h-e-l-p and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betel that they
are recruiting additional therapists in
all 50 states special offer for the
Friendship onion listeners get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
eat the world
you join us here in the no expenses
spent
studio for Billy and Dom eat the world
and today we're not only uh drinking the
world we we also have a guest with us Mr
Daniel Whittington who
created These Fine whiskeys it did not
create them he's just going to tell us
about them ah I've ruined it already
Daniel welcome to the show
thank you it's lovely to have you on
I've been listening to your podcast or
watching it on YouTube actually and I
really enjoy it I do occasionally enjoy
a whiskey and it's good to get educated
on it so um thank you very much for that
Daniel Daniel as we read out a little
bio about how you got into the world of
whiskeys is there one of these
particular whiskeys that you would think
is a good introduction to this world
classic let's start with the Brookline
would it be okay if I pull you
I'd love that now listen Billy Billy's
quite an expert in whiskey so you tell
me how much bills just a bit more than a
splash well give her give her a good
Swig well there you go lovely
lovely look at that time just well you
read that out I'm just gonna smell it
I'm not gonna taste it okay now I'll
read some stuff out about Daniel and
then Daniel you can tell us about the uh
the classic lady Daniel Whittington our
lovely guest spent 18 years as a
full-time studio and touring musician
before moving back to Austin Texas and
Diving head first into business
education and the world of whiskey with
an e and we'll get into that in a second
Daniel is currently the chancellor of
Wizard Academy a business school of
entrepreneurs he's also the founder of
whiskey marketing School based out of
the Wizard Academy he's the co-founder
of crowded Barrel whiskey company the
world's first crowd-sourced whiskey
Distillery and the whiskey tribe the
world's most engaged online whiskey
Community he co-hosts two of the largest
whiskey YouTube channels in the world
the whiskey Vault and the whiskey tribe
is also the founding member of the taxi
Texas whiskey Association and currently
serving as its president what
I'm gonna need a drink after that cheers
there we go
Daniel are you drinking the same as us
are you drinking the classic lady
of course I am let's try it well
actually before I try it here's my first
question I've got from you yeah Daniel
uh you may have noticed I'm a Scotsman
and therefore no everything there is to
know about whiskey and golf
that's right just just in the DNA it's
just in the DNA but yeah when I have a
malt is this a malt whiskey
whenever I have a malt whiskey I always
put a little dash of water in it yes is
that the right thing to do is it the
right thing
well so here so we always say uh the
definition of good whiskey is whiskey
you like full stop right and the right
way to drink it is however you want
second stop and the right glassware is
one that doesn't leak
that's
it
now you will find whiskey professionals
will always have water a water back with
whiskey and they'll add it in increments
to sort of open up and and access what's
in there now yeah that's very common
I've been with Billy who the entire time
that I've known him has had a little
couple of dashes of water in his whiskey
I've been with Billy on nights out where
when he's put water in his whiskey
people have gone no no what are you
doing and Billy said that's how you're
supposed to drink whiskey and they've
gone no that's sacrile is that sacriley
I guess it's different in different
parts of the world right but as a
Scotsman telling a Scotsman how to drink
whiskey is a little cheeky yeah you
won't often see that in the U.S uh in
the U.S you're not going to see as much
with bourbon and things like that
they'll just be drinking it typically
um but uh that's primarily because
there's a lot more column distillation
versus pot still distillation but that's
a super nerdy level of production wow
this is what we wanted to get
of whiskey and I think my first question
for you Daniel and hopefully this also
helps out the listeners and the Watchers
back home what is whiskey what is it oh
that's a good well done well thanks it's
alcohol but what what let's start from
the beginning yeah yeah well legally it
has to start with grain so you can't
start like a Moonshiner with a sugar to
help get the fermentation going or any
other things right so it has to be grain
and uh and then it has to be fermented
and then distilled in some fashion and
then put into Oak barrels and then aged
and depending on the country there are
small changes to each of those steps but
that's basically it the grain
it's a fermented distilled barrel-aged
Billy let me just should I say very
quickly if someone if someone were to
come along at that point and investigate
said whiskey company and noticed ah you
didn't distill it in the way that we
expected you to in in the whiskey
fashion or you didn't Cask it in the way
that you we expect you to would they not
be allowed to call it a whiskey and what
could they then what would they then
call it well it depends on the country
let's all go with America yeah but um uh
there's only I mean distillation is
distillation that's just the separation
of of alcohol and various chemicals yeah
so you you either distill or you don't
there's not right so that's a set thing
yeah but in the U.S if you add something
other than grain before you ferment it's
no longer a whiskey it's a a distilled
Spirit specialty or maybe a rum or maybe
it depending on what you're using right
um
if you aged it in something other than
oak then it's not a
it's not a fundamental whiskey category
but there's a category in the U.S that's
called distilled Spirit specialty which
is a catch-all for we don't know what to
do with this
right and so there's a lot of stuff that
just falls into the what is that oh
something it's alcohol so whiskey always
distilled always aged an oak
in Oak traditionally yeah for it to
follow all of the rules my this is
fantastic by the way just just this is a
smooth whiskey by the way this one is
from Isla right now I love this one not
only is one of my favorite distilleries
but this is typically isle is known for
Smoky yeah right Laphroaig and you know
kalila and art bag just Hefty punch you
in the throat kind of and I love that
but this is an unpeated whiskey so it's
from a Territory famous for smoke but
there's no smokes
in this no wow you get that sort of like
light Briny freshness
and as we can see from this bottle I'll
put a little close up on this side here
in my camera
there you go but in this particular
whiskey there is not an e it is spelled
without an e and my lovely father today
pointed out that a whiskey spell without
the e is from Scotland and all all other
whiskeys that including e are not from
the incredible country of Scotland where
you come from yeah I was born there what
a fantastic
Johnny could you bring in a receptacle
that where we could uh put spent whiskey
otherwise we're gonna get drunk driving
home Olivia I will tell you the the e no
e thing ironically While most American
whiskeys will lay themselves with an e
in the legal beverage code in America
it's spelled with no e oh is it so where
did they eat come from well it was I
mean Ireland did it first to
differentiate their product on the
market right and then because so much of
American Roots went back to Irish
uh connections they sort of took that
spelling along with it brilliant I'm
Gonna Keep on this one just now until we
talk a bit more about this one let's
talk a little bit more about this one
would would you say in in terms of the
the whiskeys that you represent this is
this is the best entry level whiskey
does it get a little more specific these
are
for for the three that you have that I
sent for this uh the I would I would
order it Lottie which we just did and
then the 12 on your far left and then
The Cask anamu which is the middle
because that's a special edition of
theirs let me have a look at that again
so why why is this one and because
whenever I think of a naily whiskey I do
think of that oh that is a lot as soon
as you smell it and I thought that was
because of the P up there
it is therefore I thought
well you can't make a whiskey without
that yeah how did he do that eating
process so what happens with grain is
you have to Malt the barley and these
are all 100 barley that's a malt right
it's all barley so no corn no wheat it's
just barley and traditionally and
historically all the whiskey coming out
of Ireland and Scotland was smoky right
because what happens is you have to
ferment it I mean affirmative you have
to molt it which is this process that we
won't go totally into but it allows the
the grain to open up and be accessible
to the yeast so it can convert into
alcohol now uh to freeze that process
you have they would heat it to freeze
the process and traditionally in
Scotland what are you going to do when
you need to heat something you're going
to burn pee right so it comes from that
firewood
and that's where it comes from well
around about the Advent of gas heating
and ways of heating things other than
burning logs or burning peat bricks all
of a sudden that became a flavor choice
and so now it's done because you want
that flavor but not because you have to
right so now you can just you can dry
malted barley uh you know with just a
any kind of heat that you can get
electrical heat or gas heating or and
you won't have any smoke in it and
that's what you're drinking with this
it's a hard time for hiring you need a
hiring partner built for hard times
that's indeed if you're hiring you need
indeed because indeed is the hiring
partner where you can attract interview
and hire all in one place and indeed is
the only job site where you're
guaranteed to find quality applications
that meet your must-have requirements or
else you don't pay instead of spending
hours on multiple job sites hoping to
find candidates with the right skills
you need one powerful hiring partner
that can help you do it all indeed
partners with you on every step of the
hiring process find great talent through
time saving tools like indeed instant
match assessments and virtual interviews
with instant match as soon as you
sponsor a post you get a short list of
quality candidates with resumes on
indeed that match your job description
and you can invite them to apply right
away plus you only pay for Quality
applications that meet your must-have
have requirements one of the things I
love about indeed is that it makes
hiring all in one place so easy you
don't have to search for potential
employees they come to you and indeed
delivers four times more hires than all
other job sites combined according to
Talent nest
start hiring right now with a 75 dollar
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com onion offer valid
through March 31st go to indeed.com
onion to claim your 75 credit before
March 31st indeed.com slash onion terms
and conditions apply need to hire you
need indeed
today's episode is sponsored by honey I
love honey because I like a bargain and
I can't be bothered going and finding
cooping codes and all that honey will
find it for you get it in and you save
the money thanks to Honey manually
searching for cooping codes is a thing
of the past honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one to fit
your car honey supports over 30 000
stores online they range from sites that
have Tech and gaming products to popular
fashion brands and even food delivery
imagine you're shopping in one of your
favorite sites yeah when you go to
checkout the honey button drops down and
all you have to do is Click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches for crippins it can find for
that site if honey finds a working
coopin you'll watch the prices drop
that's fantastic I mean I like saving
money as much as the next man and like
you said sometimes you'll see something
online you think yeah I like the look of
that but I'd like it to be a little bit
cheaper you put your little coupon fun
coding it's cheaper straight away that's
what honey does amazing honey has found
its over 17 million members over two
billion dollars in savings wow if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up messing out it's literally
free and installs in a few seconds and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself
that solid and supporting this podcast
and you know me Bills I'd never
recommend something I don't use get
honey for free at joinhoney.com onion
that's joinhoney.com
and is that the point in the process
where they spread all out sort of on on
the ground yeah that's the malting floor
that's where they're malting it and
turning it with shovels and amazing
yeah not very many places do that
anymore that's if you can go to one go
to it I think it was it I think I saw it
and um a Balvenie
yeah they do it there I'm sure
and usually they'll have like a
percentage of their MO they do
themselves like that and then they'll
mix it with bulk produced malt because
you won't be able to keep up with the
production needs doing it all by a
shovel these days so that's incredible
that is that would be what I would like
in a whiskey I don't like it when it's
too too hard it's just it's like hard
work try to drink some of those guys but
um that's amazing to hear that it's
through heat and I thought it was
somehow the water gone through somehow
you all oily whiskeys had to be like
that
no you would think that even the water
going through the Limestone or the that
grain bed that they're sourcing that
would bring smoke into it but it really
does and didn't make it through the
process so what why did you smoke the
grain excuse me Daniel I'm sorry I
interrupted you that
um why why whiskey for you Daniel why
not vodka why not rum I mean there's
obviously oh because vodka doesn't taste
like anything well that's true and
honestly run this uh is
I haven't been able to get in a room
there's this sort of metallic note to
run that always throws me a little and
this is not my preference I was in the
whiskey originally because it was easy
and I could get Irish whiskey when I was
touring anywhere I knew I could get my
hands on decent Irish whiskey and then
one day my dad poured me uh a Scotch
called Longhorn 16. it's from the
longhorn Distillery and uh it was a
turns out almost impossible to get
single malt from a Distillery that Ray
really rarely released their own single
mode they usually go into blends
and I took one sip of it and my whole
world went oh this is what's possible in
a drink wow there's all this experience
of Adventure and change and flavors and
that was it that was no looking back
after that
so now you are
if you don't mind the scene a high level
give me a help with the world so merely
Somalia Somalia whiskey Somalia yeah
yeah we started that school and uh we
pulled in the training from the wine
Somalia programs and things like that
and then partnered it with marketing
training so for the Layman out there
yeah what what is the sommelier both in
both in any kind of alcoholic beverage
that you could do and in a general
extent Somalia these days is being used
as a synonym for an expert in like a
food industry thing Origins are all wine
now you I've seen water sommelier guy
those guys
right they're all over the place but
effectively it just means a very
knowledgeable
expert quote unquote in a specific
category and let these great wine
somaliers do you think you could drink a
whiskey and narrow it down to
certainly an area or even get into uh
every week a couple of times a week so
my on my campus we have a room with over
3 000 unique whiskeys in it
and periodically when we get a couple
hours and we're basically done for the
day a handful of us will run in there
and someone will go into the room pull
and pour something and hand it to you
and then you've got to try to figure out
what it is really uh every once in a
while I can guess the Distillery wow and
what it is but it's really only pattern
recognition so I have to be really
familiar with that one I can usually get
it down to the base grain or the region
of the world where it's coming from or
how they're aging it amazing and I love
I love your uh idea which I've seen in
Wayne as well that there's no good or
bad that's really just what you like but
like when you guys do that thing where
you you get the the the flavors you know
what is it as a caramel is it let's do
that oh on this yeah and see if we get
it so here's what you're going to want
to do when you do this right you don't
try to understand what you think should
be in a whiskey just ask yourself what
does this remind me of right that's it
just only ask yourself that question
my drunk uncle
done
[Laughter]
did he work did he wear a cologne
Aramis
right I'm going to say caramel because I
can definitely smell caramel there that
would be an every whiskey that's one of
the primary chemicals that show up in
the interaction between Oak and grain
distilled Spirits okay yeah I have to
admit I'm getting a strawberry toasted
vanilla strong smell of whiskey more
than anything else yeah yeah that's very
accurate come on come on what you get
the sweetness there's a sugar like yeah
like the direction of honey yeah yeah
like a honey
it's nice that now that you say it
although that might just be suggest
suggestion no well okay so you can't
there is such a thing as like uh
something pop in your head because
someone said it and you recognize it
you'll never be able to power a
suggestion something that's a hundred
percent not there what what about
um I could be wrong here but I'm getting
a citrus
yes what I was going to say is add an
orange peel to that like you would on a
cocktail where you have like an orange
peel what's going on yeah I'm getting
amazing news I think it's just the
Scotsman and the whiskey no it's not an
incredible news that's why I can never
get too close to them he's got strings I
do have a stench here I was gonna say
don't invite Billy to the room with 3
000 whiskeys
um challenge accepted the uh
the uh there's a bit of a like a damp I
don't know if you have any experience
with Farms but there's a bit of a damp
grain nose in this one for me that I
really love because it's a little bit
younger malt comparatively I think this
one tends to be in the six to eight
range somewhere in there I'm not sure
which there the brook Lottie doesn't try
to recreate The Identical whiskey every
time
what they try to do is get in the in the
same profiles if you loved this before
in the next bash you're gonna love it
again and it's definitely like you know
90 there but they Embrace batch
variations I love that because they're
smaller so they know that you know we're
just trying to aim to this same thing
but it's going to be slightly different
each time can we move on another one
we cannot change exactly we must yes
let's move on all right because we're
both driving unfortunately Daniel I'm
getting a lift now
now let's do this backwards do the
middle one next this one yeah
yeah The Cask Animo
okay now do you watch it and splash do
you want to tell us anything about this
or should we just go blind uh
I'll tell you what let's go blind it's
darker so with no knowledge of what's in
here
go back this time and ask yourself that
same question again and what you're
going to ask not only what do I remember
or what do I recognize or what does it
remind me of you're always going to ask
how is this different from the one that
I just had
and I know from watching your YouTube
that uh it's hard to do whiskey after
whiskey really you should do one whiskey
that's what they do or they try one per
episode because the more you get into it
you forget what you've done and yeah
and the good news is a b comparison is
one of the best ways to understand
something that's great okay so here we
go highlight variations
oh completely different um oh that's
totally different that that feels much
more like uh a serious
you know kind of older gentleman or lady
whiskey something to be darker yeah it's
dark so you said you've seen tobacco do
you get into it might be a good show
it's a little bit more the the taste is
a little bit more complicated a darker
honey like a really a dark yeah think of
it as um maybe start heading the way as
like a toasted almond yeah yeah honeyed
almonds or uh I was that's interesting
that you said that because I was gonna
say burnt toast but I didn't want to
offend you like yeah
that's why
sulfur you're getting what falls into
the category of a sulfuric toasted
almond right now that's coming from the
Sherry castle and there's another I was
gonna ask that's the difference it's in
a different cast the same method
different casting
people have a blend but this one's
relying more on Sherry Cask Sherry there
is a there's an overpowering not not
incredibly pleasant smell of like an old
like a dish cloth that you've washed the
dishes with too much what is that that
is that same is that so I attribute that
one to that mustiness of the Sherry cast
the Cherry barrels mostly that's it it's
like it's been like you've got something
damp and then you left it but it's not
it's not totally unpleasant but it's
like it's quite overpowering yeah you
almost described it as Rich yes right
like this is this is like you know elbow
pads and leather arm chairs and
absolutely matches sliding your pipe
tobacco now is is whiskey the first
country known to have create that's a
whiskey is
Scotland the first country to be
attributed with creating whiskey so
there is no like absolutely guaranteed
this is who did it first now the first
that it showed up in writing was in
Ireland
right and 1405. wow and it was in a it
was in a record of basically the
historical record of a clan where they
said that this guy drank himself to
death
and it was and it was due to the the
Water of Life right and uh now that was
not what we were drinking yeah yeah
right this like casc aging and all that
kind of stuff that's that's in the last
200 300 you know drinking firewall
they're drinking basically pachin if
you've ever had like just anything they
could ferment grain mostly but sometimes
other things usually clear uh not fancy
but that's the closest to it and then
almost a hundred years later it shows up
in writing in Scotland for the first
time right and of course it shows up and
effectively a bookkeepers report
really oh yeah yeah but which basically
it was the um it's the tax record for
like hey this guy we gave him x amount
there was a friar we gave him x amount
barley to make whiskey with right
talking about
oh God we need to stop soon tax
one of my favorite things in the world
is the the phrase for the little bit of
whiskey in the barrel that you don't pay
tax on do you know what that's called
you did tell me this once the angel
share
that's because it evaporates into the
air yeah so for like 20 of the barrel
you don't pay tax on it because that's
the angel share I love that yeah because
it's gone it doesn't exist anymore and
you played in bands all your life I I my
first band was called the Angels here oh
that's great oh yeah
well now we know where it all went yeah
well Daniel let me ask you this because
I'm sure there'd be quite a few viewers
and listeners out there that might be
interested in in this
if if someone out there watching the
show had a kind of two-week break in
their work and they were heading to
Scotland
do you know of kind of three or four
distilleries that they should absolutely
hit up tour in Scotland
that one's so tough yeah
um head up to space side
right so I was like you know
aberdeenshire or you know up in the and
and there's within a stone's throw
there's 30 options right and so you can
just sort of like live up there now I
would always try to book a chunk of two
or three days where you could go down to
Isla and stay on the island and just be
there yeah right I mean I was not very
populated what they've got more sheep
Than People was it something like 3 000
people and 1500 committees
right so all right but so I mean that's
probably what I would I mean there's so
many you could go up North but you're
only going to hit a handful you can go
to the West Coast but you're only going
to be able to bounce off a handful so if
you wanted to maximize your time head
right into the heart you know and start
in Edinburgh
and um and then then book some time in
Iowa definitely yeah this the space age
are all have always been my favorite and
then yeah that's no one that's the
whiskey yeah this is what this is
Bayside this came from uh when I was
working a lot in theater working in
Glasgow in Edinburgh and there's two
great great great great theaters in
Edinburgh called the lyceum in the
Traverse yeah I was working so much in
both of them that ended up I thought I'm
just going to live in Edinburgh so I
found this uh apartment with like five
bedrooms uh that was owned by a man
called uh David Campbell who's a
Scottish storyteller and his job was
basically to go around schools and stuff
and tell the stories of
you know how this mountain was there
because of two witchies that fought and
but you know all the folk tales and
tales about whiskey and and we would sit
at night and he'd his favorite was
Balvenie 15 year old Balvin yeah and
he'd open a bottle of that and we'd tell
stories and discuss Shakespeare and sing
songs and it's one of the greatest parts
of my life and whoever was in those five
bedrooms it might have been a touring
musician one week and then the next week
it was a a puppet maker and and they'd
all come into this front room and we'd
drink whiskey and talk about these
things and it was
it was incredible that's the real value
of whiskey the the real there was a a
movie that you could watch called neat
and it's a story of Kentucky bourbon but
um Freddy is a really famous figure in
Kentucky bourbon he talked about in that
uh how he one time pulled and I'm gonna
butcher his story he does it so well he
he pulled a really fancy whiskey that's
really hard to get from his The
Distillery he worked with and he poured
it for his brother and his dad and he
poured them just a little you know just
a little bit and his dad said what are
you doing
and he said well this is like this is a
really Rare whiskey you know and his dad
said no we are the fragile part of this
equation there will always be more
whiskey that's brilliant and that's the
purpose of whiskey at the end sure it's
fun to nerd out on it and of course it's
lovely to drink and if you're a nerd
like I am you really enjoy the nerding
out on it yeah but at the end of the day
it's it's social lubrication for
relationship and storytelling yeah and a
better life you know storytelling that's
yeah yeah I was in Glasgow
a long time ago now one of the one of
the trips that I went up to Glasgow was
talking to Billy about whiskey telling
him I wasn't quite sure what particular
whiskey
I liked or what worked for me and Billy
said well let's do a test let's do a
blind test and he pulled out
I think five or six different whiskeys
from different parts of Scotland and he
said he'll keep an eye on what he's
pouring me but I won't know and we'll
work out what you like and I think I
ended up on Dal Winnie is that thing
yeah they'll Winnie yeah oh yeah it's
one of the smallest distilleries in
Scotland and I think not much but really
high up there yeah yeah that's a really
great smooth and love very smooth yeah
yeah got a lot of honeysuckle yeah I
think I like it a little bit easier to
taste on the palette when it gets too
intense
it's not not quite my thing but this was
this is a good one that's very grown up
we love that very much that was a that
was great
you want to try that 12 the only
difference I don't have that one so I'm
going to switch to a different one but
the only thing that you're going to
experience differently is a different
percentage of bourbon and Sherry barrels
so all of all of these whiskeys you have
in front of you are using barrels that
used to have something else yeah I love
that isn't it Sherry and then yeah and
bourbon yeah and then other wine other
wines ports and Madeira and right
fortified ones
um
what what that's what you're drinking
American whiskeys and bourbon
why is that different why why
well
there was a rule that got a law that got
passed and very recently in world
history which is like 1900s
and it codified American whiskey Prime
categories had to use new Oak
which means they had to use barrels that
are freshly made and have never held
anything else oh wow and that that was
added in to the law by the lumber Lobby
so so that they could make more barrels
that's great so they don't they don't
get any flavor from the old barrels from
the Cherry uh sharing no they there they
can those they they don't use secondary
cast so they you they get only with the
raw charred barrels providing and that's
a lot of that American whiskey flavors
coming from new Oak right and then but
then they've empty it and they don't
have a need for it and Scotland said hey
I got an idea oh I got an idea of what
we can do with that why don't you send
us that used Barrel because it's cheaper
and uh we'll put our stuff into it
so now all of Scottish and Irish whiskey
is a blend of bourbon barrels and wine
barrels Sherry Portman so bourbon will
still sit in that barrel for 12 15 years
though
very rarely it's I mean the most of the
releases you can get on a shelf are
gonna be uh 10 or under
because I remember something from one of
your podcasts and I think you were
drinking a bourbon and had to sort of
not a better had an aftertaste and you
were saying how Scotland or Ireland will
leave that in the Barrow for longer and
it will get rid of that
yeah we don't have time to get rid of
that because the tannins and the wood
take over
you guys have time because you have used
barrels you can buy time we can't we
can't do that because it's new Oak and
it's the woods just get stronger and
stronger you get a 15 20 year old
bourbon
and the wood notes just kick you in the
mouth that's just all that's all you're
getting yeah
that law is still in place yeah oh yeah
absolutely right hold on let's have a
snifference
Daniel this is absolutely fascinating
thank you for coming in it's really good
yeah and hey a note for you on the 12 I
want you to look for when you said you
had a theater background because I
always pick this up and Sherry Cask
whiskeys
the fog machines
there's one yeah
yes that create the backstage smoke
which is like an ever-present yeah Aura
in all theaters
yeah absolutely I have a very delicate
palette oh I know that
you're very delicate yeah yeah I see
if I like that I like I like that I
might like that the most it's quite
smooth
I'm gonna drink this because I don't
have that avalor 12 because I went to
get it to drink with you guys and it was
empty I don't know how that happened
well it's one of your friends obviously
yeah but this is Balcones which is a
distillery in Texas and they are making
Scottish style malt their whole approach
is I mean they actually even their
fermenters and their Stills came from
Scotland that's great and um so they're
doing used oak on this release just like
Scotland does but uh and they're using a
Scottish barley and I don't know about
this one but they also use a Scottish
barley called Golden promise and uh but
it's aged in Texas so even with this
color
it's like three years old
which is in Scotland just now whiskey
right it has to be at least three and
America it doesn't matter it can be it
can be an oak for five minutes oh really
ninja whiskey it's it's considered
whiskey that looks nice though we have a
note here from Johnny clothes
who says uh some of the flavors
associated with classic lady the things
like fresh mint lemon drops fresh cup
wildflowers what creates the flavors of
something that clearly isn't in the
whiskey where does that come from uh so
the same chemical that is clearly mint
and is in mint
is also present in other ways and other
things so like for example there's a
chemical called isoamyl acetate course
you would know it as banana ah
yeah right yeah yeah so that chemical is
in banana that's what makes banana taste
like banana that chemical also shows up
in Grain yeast and grain yeast
fermentations right
and if especially if done badly it can
Dominate and you get this whiskey that's
vaguely banana smelling this is this is
intriguing Daniel because my friend here
to my right Dominic Monahan oh yeah he
just he he bought me a book you're
obsessed with this book this book I'm
obsessed by is called the body by Bill
Bryson and uh Paul Bryson is a damn
genius have you read this book The Body
yeah when it just goes through all the
different parts of your body and I was
just reading about taste buds and
chemicals and how you taste different
things and basically they don't yet know
because it's it's it's it's one of the
um senses that they haven't looked
really closely at but it's what you're
talking about it's basically same thing
with the nose a chemical yeah a chemical
is in a banana but it sends something
else so we just go banana but it's
actually just a chemical touching your
um so to answer that question uh exactly
notes of that or replicate and overlap
with other things you would recognize
they start showing up as early as when
you make the The MASH which is like
basically a porridge you just boil not
boil it's too hot but you heat up the
grain and extract all the sugars right
they're already chemicals showing up
there that will make it all the way
through to the final product and then
you ferment it and the yeast production
creates a whole other level of flavors
some of which won't make it through
distillation and some of which do and
then you distill and based on your
choices of distillation
some chemicals make it through and some
don't and then you age it and new
chemicals get created because it's
interacting with the wood and the other
uh finishes and new chemicals and
flavors show up right so there are some
things you'll taste in what we're
drinking that were there
and fermentation wow and there's there
are some chemicals that you'll taste
that only showed up 10 years into aging
Daniel I like this one I would say the
abalua is that the way to say it yeah
yeah I think it might be my favorite
it's got all right it's got a smoothness
to it that I appreciate but also that so
you like that Sherry Cask strong which
is interesting because darwini is not a
strong Sherry casket Distillery remember
my palette is changing have you ever
tried uh have you ever tried deanston
I've not I'm not very good with whiskey
12.
uh deanston you say deanston 12. get
your hands on that one
I think it might be up your alley have
you seen the film with nail and I Daniel
yeah I think that has a great
correlation with sitting down and
enjoying a whiskey because obviously
both of those characters in the film are
Keen alcohol Drinkers and when you're
watching when you're watching people
that's one way to put it it's nice it's
nice to kind of feel that Tipsy feeling
Billy and I were talking about this the
other day
uh I think
two oh no it wasn't billion I have
someone else but a couple of drinks
nowadays in my older days two or three
drinks of something is great yeah little
tipsy oh yeah you know no Tom Waits said
uh I don't want another drink I just
want that last one again yeah that's
broke yeah that's it I mean too I know I
know actually no it wasn't Tom Waits I
don't want another drink I just want
that last one again at what happened
just smoke nose it was
um damn how did I miss that one it was
one of Texas great songwriters James
McMurtry all right okay who you may not
know but you ever seen Lonesome Dove
yeah sure the the uh Robert film the TV
series yeah yeah uh his dad is Larry
McMurtry who wrote Lonesome Dove wow and
he's a songwriter in Texas uh based on
living in Austin but he wrote that line
I don't want to know the drink I just
want that last one again yeah I said and
and damn if I haven't we haven't all
felt that one um yeah just that nice and
I think
you know to be enjoyed responsibly but
yeah whiskey gives you that lovely at
like some people in Scotland don't drink
whiskey because they think it gets them
aggressive
and I think that's a that's a known
thing in Scotland but I think that's
just drinking too much
is that lovely sinking into your seat
and just enjoying chat and just enjoying
an evening maybe somebody brings a
guitar you just kind of that love
someone's lit a fire oh God you know it
just softens the edges yeah it's like a
gaussian blur yeah yeah your host yes
just said to you you take the comfy
chair tonight no no no no no no have it
have it you have that you sit down maybe
you're wearing your father's clothes
yeah and he said would you like to smoke
a pipe I would love to and while I'm
lighting this pipe done would you sing
that song your grandfather used to sing
yeah yeah
yeah Billy's totally right I think
whiskey is at the top of the chart of an
alcoholic beverage to be enjoyed
responsibly to make you feel a little
cozy makes you feel cozy you know
absolutely and it's it's complicated and
it's wonderful and it's just a to sit
with friends and open a good bottle of
whiskey is just a lovely thing uh yeah
Daniel uh because I'm sure we've got a
lot of people listening to the podcast
who are
very much entry level into whiskey
right what would what would you say
would be you know if you're going to dip
your foot into the water and introduce
yourself to something that's going to
help you well be welcomed into that
world where's a good place to start
uh a bar I know that sounds strange but
but uh buying committing to a bottle of
whiskey is is a real deal yeah I mean if
you don't like it that's money down the
drain and like another 700 milliliters
of spirit that you're like what am I
gonna do with this right so one of the
best things is to find not and not like
uh let no nothing that advertises shots
right yeah just like find a bar with a
reasonable whiskey selection maybe 20
whiskeys minimum of any kind
right and then just make a habit of
going there and and if if you ask right
they'll pour your tasting quarters
they're not used to it and they won't
know how to charge it or ring it up but
if if you tip well and you're kind
then you can say look I don't care how
you charge me I just only want you to
pour me a half ounce of each thing that
I request I love it because I want to
try three things
that'll add up to two ounces which is a
double yeah I'll effectively have one
double one double I'll have tried four
things and I'll have learned something
and and picked your favorite exactly
yeah and you you charge me however you
want and don't you feel I I feel that
there's it's quite hard to find those
bars in America maybe not in Texas but
certainly in California it's not
advertise themselves it's restaurant
bars yeah definitely restaurants are a
better bet yeah because they have a
gentler atmosphere yeah it's hard to
find just a bar where you could go in
and speak to the barman and and get to
know
and honestly if it was beer you would
just send them to the library or to the
office yeah yeah in Santa Monica yeah
yeah
yeah or somewhere like that where it's
just yeah exactly but not so much
whiskey and then you know Scotland the
the old men in Scotland is you you might
know this always order a half and a half
you always order a half a beer and a
half a whiskey because if they drink
just whiskey they get drunk too fast if
they drink just beer they don't get
drunk at all so they always drink it's a
half and a half
when I was in Ireland so I had a surgery
I can't drink carbonation right because
it just ruins me right but I love
Guinness so we're in Ireland and I'm
like of course I'm gonna drink Guinness
I I have to so I we went to hang out
with someone and I said I could take a
half pint of Guinness and he said you
know we have a name for that uh you
don't have to ask for a half pint of
Guinness you can just order a blouse is
it really wow
I was like oh okay I can't remember what
friend told me this but they went to
Ireland and they said they went and
ordered the Guinness and said you know
uh could I have a paint again please and
they said yeah do you want uh a fast one
or a slow one he said uh I'll take a
slow one he said great do you want a
fast one while you're waiting
I thought that was brilliant welcome to
Ireland
well this has been brilliant this is
great Daniel and she's really fun we'd
love to have you back on and maybe we
can maybe you can come back on and talk
about some of the more kind of extensive
world of whiskey obviously I tell you
what next time let's do Texas
and I'll mail it to you because you
won't ever be able to get it but but all
of the uh all of the distillers making
Texas whiskey are friends of mine great
because I'm a Texas whiskey maker yes
and just before we go just for my own
thing what what was your when you were
doing music what what were you uh a
guitarist or a drummer or I whatever
they paid me to play oh you play
Everything uh my first instrument was
drums right uh my second instrument is
rhythm guitar electric or acoustic right
and then if need be I could fill in on
base and electric as needed and and then
a lot of vocals but most of my money
came from drums and rhythm guitar just
touring around the studio
mostly Nashville LA and California and
yeah really great fun yeah we'd love to
have you back on to talk about Texas
whiskey and also there's an amazing
culture in Ireland with whiskey there's
an amazing culture in Japan oh yeah
these whiskey has been a very big
um and I gotta thank you guys because uh
I told you made me look cool to my two
boys there you go that's what we do we
just meet people my boys are my boys are
14. and 11.
and
I've got two YouTube channels totaling
almost a million subscribers yeah but
they don't give a crap about that so
but
hey boys I I hang out
with the dudes yeah we were just
watching Lord of the Rings and they were
like I'm gonna hang out with those guys
like two weeks from now we're gonna
drink whiskey and all of a sudden I saw
the light of respect
um
their dad is a real guy all of a sudden
that's great well this has been
brilliant Daniel oh wait we need to give
it some scores
here's my request I want you to rate it
in arbitrary measures and I'll give you
an example are you ready yeah so I would
give Brooke Lottie
uh 14 out of 19 flannel shirts oh right
okay and and I would rate abalore
134 out of 200 Audis
we can do that we break our scores up
into uh we normally do but I mean we can
still do it we could just we could just
give them scores so for taste so we do
taste right
Aesthetics any usefulness not for all
three though we'll just do taste for
this one
we'll do Aesthetics for this one oh gosh
three more drinks usefulness no we just
remember okay taste for this one Dom but
marked in the way that Daniel would like
Chase for Brooke laddy it was good but
it's I'm not I wasn't feeling it as much
as I below I'm gonna give it a
I'm gonna give it a
6.2 out of ten
Lamborghini countaches or Lamborghini
wow all right wow for me
I would give that 24
out of 28
for Edinburgh streets oh that's good
yeah you liked it yeah well it was like
an Edinburgh Street drink for me love
that hello you're graded it at a certain
level but your category choice is
already elevated
Aesthetics the bottle how it looks we're
doing here this is how it looks done how
it looks it's a beautiful the bottle the
color how it sits in the glass
I mean that's beautiful look at that
look at that label I'm gonna give I mean
it's a that's a lovely part of the
whiskey it's lovely though I'm going to
give that a
8.8
out of
10 Persian cats
ah
yes
lovely I'll give that
because that's lovely though it is it
might be the best one I feel the whiskey
just touching me now oh I'll give that
26 out of 20 again
27 drunk out of 30.
sun rises
hold on
and when you're done you're gonna have
to show us where on the whiskey bottle
the whiskey touched you oh yeah sunrises
and Lewis
I was saying Scotland oh it's on the
west coast there it's beautiful you can
surf there dumb oh I mean just finishing
a bottle of that as the sun comes up
what could be nicer me and you John I
love it get where wetsuits on and then
we go love it and then finally our final
category is usefulness we do usefulness
how useful is this in your life how
useful is this 12 year old bottle of
Apple so is that a fragment is that a
pragmatic what kind of you you can make
your own decisions there really okay
well wait a minute we never got we've
never got Daniel's aesthetic how does
the abber lure this abalore look to you
we forgotten man I'm gonna rate that
pretty damn high as well yeah it looks
like uh
uh
I'm gonna rate it 13 out of 15 mirsham
pipes
awesome yeah that's awesome I see
sitting in the weather there with that
pipe now usefulness obviously after a
long stressful day's Works nice to have
a little glass of whiskey just could you
could you put it in anything could you
could you add it to like a shortbread
and give it a little whiskey Tang I
don't know could you I don't know could
you you could definitely put it in a
little uh hip flask and take it into a
concert with you no save you some money
um that's an expensive it warms you up
but it definitely it warms you up by the
fire
I mean it does what whiskey does I mean
if you're sitting in your house and you
said oh and I need to eat something this
isn't going to help much is it not the
most versatile of things you've ever
done but it does like I said it does the
job that it's supposed to I'm going to
give it
four
out of nine ring rates
oh wow
that's fair yeah well I'm gonna say well
Daniel did see it it opens you up to
conversation yeah
and and and just just enjoying each
other's company yeah so I'll give that
nine or a ten
wow friends around the fire
ah damn it come on Daniel give us a time
how useful is it to you
so I value something that is beautiful
because it's not practical ah I see
right and this is not practical if if
you just for practical purposes I can
get you a 20 bourbon right so if we're
going I'm gonna approach this totally
opposite
for the raw pragmatism right okay I'm
gonna give this three out of ten
uh dually pickup trucks oh my God good
guy lovely nice
[Music]
well thank you you're gonna stay with us
because you've picked an amazing song
that you think is funky I'm gonna write
funky for you funky for you but that
could that concludes this amazing
episode of billion dummy in the world
and we're now going to reconvene no
we're just going to stay we're gonna
stay here
and we're gonna find out what song you
think is funky so do you wanna do you
want to cue it up for us Daniel what is
this song
and so Foy Vance is an Irishman who is
really a gospel southern gospel root
singer
sort of like Van Morrison who should
like just really belonged in the
American Roots but somehow was Irish
okay and uh he brings this soul
but but there's that Irish folk history
that that's just that overlap is insane
and the song is called
hang on I'm just scrolling to this
person heading to page three I can pull
it up for you I've got it the song is
called Signs of Life yes indeed yeah
let's hear it Travis come on give us it
through our ear holes
[Music]
love it it goes very very well with the
whiskey this is this is what Daniel's
done now whiskey music he's chosen the
right music he's sitting there the kids
have gone to bed
he's sitting there himself with a glass
of whiskey and he thought what am I
going to put on I know what I'll put on
and there it is something nice and kind
of comfortable and homely something that
you know even before you know it yeah
it'll make You Weep For A History you
never had full events so we rate it
Daniel we rate it in a category of uh
Brahms to Prince Brahms being not funky
at all and Brent's being extreme uh
Prince being extremely funky maybe you
could would you like me to or would you
like to Tom
rate it first please you be my guess
well I'll tell you where I would rate
that in the funk um because I do think
if I was sitting on a leather chair
drinking that nice glass of whiskey was
that one called I like that one
I was drinking that and I put that on
that would be absolutely perfect so I'm
going to give that but would it be funky
is it it's funky for me in that moment
and it's funky in the way that Prince
was during the parade album that's funky
oh yes I didn't even think about that
from the movie yeah it was a movie it
was like a heartbeat under the Cherry
yeah yeah oh so good
all right so if you view Prince as a
pulse he's the funkmeister
then yes I agree yeah there you go
that's an agreement
great I was gonna say early career Paul
Young Funk oh nice yeah pretty pretty
funky too I can give you that yeah well
that is a fantastic song Thank you very
much for that Daniel it's made me want
to go and listen to one of these albums
actually we will put that particular
song by Foy Vance on our Spotify uh
playlist the Friendship onion come
follow us on the uh Spotify playlist
there's a lot of Pretenders but there's
only one official one
Daniel it's been an absolute pleasure I
have to say sranjiva slangy it's nice to
have you on Daniel we'll have you on
again and we can get into American
whiskey and the culture of that too
or maybe not by that face
Texas let's get you some Texas yeah
let's just purely Texas I love Texas
surely Texas all right thank you very
much for coming on that's wonderful
thank you cheers guys thank you thank
you
dumb I love that William that was
amazing that's it we've run out of time
that we've drunk enough whiskey I think
just stop there Tom we've we've gone so
far into this whiskey experience and
done so much time in it they were
actually gonna stay here to say bye to
you guys instead of moving back to our
normal Studio well that was fantastic
listen if you're an expert in something
in particular and you want to come on
the show and Educators and tell us all
about it please get in touch with us
that's uh the Friendship onion at
castmedia.com that's cast with a k or
you can leave any comments questions or
concerns on our YouTube channel come
follow us on Spotify rate review And
subscribe to us because it helps us make
more episodes anything else uh don't
forget you can get the merchandise uh
the
friendshiponionpodcast.com and uh if
there's anything you want on merch like
a billion Dome uh eat the world or a
bottle of whiskey or whatever it is or
maybe the the map of America has a hand
just let us know we'll make it you can
have it
brilliant fantastic we're gonna we're
gonna stop recording now but we're gonna
start drinking more whiskey and we'll
see you guys next week I'll take that
one home
[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your poster
baby you're my
[Music]